so weit von der erde entfernt habe noch
nie eine vom menschen ausgesandte sonde
ein objekt untersucht ultima thule
befindet sich im kupfergürtel jenseits
der umlaufbahn von neptun und pluto und
damit auch besonders weit von der sonne
entfernt und die sonde new horizons ist
genau heute daran vorbei geflogen und
hat erste bilder geschickt und direkt
eines der ersten rätsel um das objekt
gelöst jetzt den clip zum science
fiction nur hier gibt es täglich
faszinierendes science videos abonniert
den kanal nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
herzlich willkommen sich die sonne new
horizons im januar 2005 auf den weg zum
pluto machte war die welt noch eine
andere pluto war noch ein planet und das
objekt an dem new horizons heute
vorbeiflog gar nicht entdeckt was war
geschehen
im jahr des stabs von new horizons zum
pluto wurde ein planet mit einer
ähnlichen größe entdeckt er riss das war
ein problem auf denn es wurden noch
weitere ziemlich großer brocken da
draußen aufgespürt ist drohte eine wahre
planeten flut die internationale
astronomische union zog deshalb die
notbremse die neu entdeckten planeten
wurden zum zwergplaneten erklärt und das
hat er dann auch konsequenzen für pluto
er wurde zum zwergplaneten degradiert
mio reisens wurde plötzlich keine
mission mehr zum letzten noch nicht mehr
inspizierten planeten pluto sondern zu
einem von vielen zwergplaneten noch
immer hält die diskussion dazu an und
die definition was denn nun ein planet
ist und was nicht wird immer wieder in
frage gestellt hat ja und ultima thule
war noch gar nicht entdeckt klar war nur
dass war mit new horizons objekte im
kupfergürtel passieren würde aber es
waren bis dato noch keine auf seiner
flugbahn bekannt dass sollte sich 2014
mit 2014 69 ändern da wurde das objekt
nämlich entdeckt es ist rund 30
kilometer lang rund 6,4 milliarden
kilometer von uns entfernt und hat eine
sehr seltsame form das wurde 2017 und
2018 festgestellt mit zahlreichen
teleskopen wurde dabei die flugbahn von
2014 m 69 beobachtet er ist allerdings
so weit von der sonne entfernt dass er
kein licht reflektiert oder viel zu
wenig für diese entfernung allerdings
verdeckt er immer wieder sterne und
dabei wurde festgestellt dass sie nicht
einfach hell und war dunkel werden
sondern abgedunkelt werden
dann wieder etwas heller werden dann
wieder etwas dunkler und dann erst
wieder endgültig hell ultima thule muss
also eine form wie zwei aneinander
hängen ja kugeln oder brocken haben oder
so ähnlich als sich nur reisens aber
jetzt näherte stellte die sonne etwas
sehr seltsames fest ultima thule macht
etwas unerwartetes statt wie bei
unregelmäßigen objekten licht
unregelmäßig zu reflektieren macht das
ultima thule nicht eigentlich paradox
doch new horizons konnte das rätsel
heute lösen und die nasa konnte gerade
auf einer pressekonferenz das
forschungsergebnis präsentieren ultima
thule dreht sich sehr speziell und
rotiert wie ein propeller zeigt uns also
immer dieselbe seite wodurch sich an der
reflektion nichts ändern kann
damit ist das erste rätsel gelöst das
wird morgen also spannend was noch so
alles an daten zur erde gelangt die
fotos werden dann deutlich schärfer und
wir können sehr gespannt sein was das am
weitesten von der erde entfernte und
untersuchte objekt noch so für
geheimnisse preisgibt davon abhängig
will das forschungsteam übrigens noch
einen namen vorschlagen ultima thule
wollen nämlich nicht der endgültige name
sein also das video zu den neuen neu
entdeckten geheimnissen dann morgen und
wenn ihr es garantiert als erstes sehen
wollt dann abonniert unseren whatsapp
newsletter da gibt es das video
zuallererst dafür hier draufklicken und
hier geht es weiter mit dem musikvideo
von astrophysiker und queen gitarrist
brian may der heute auf dem
youtube-kanal einen song zu new horizons
veröffentlicht hat viel spaß dabei bis
dann also darum nicht drauf klicken bis
dann
bleibt dran